hi I'm Sal Khan founder of Khan Academy  as you know we are not-for-profit with a  mission of providing a free world-class  education for anyone anywhere what that  means is unlimited personalized practice  not just in math but across subjects in  grades  it also means tools for teachers so they  can meet every student where they are  and we're already reaching tens of  millions of students every year but the  opportunity is to reach hundreds of  millions and not just reach them but  make sure that we're having a deep  impact that's why we're doing efficacy  studies with hundreds of thousands of  students around the world together I  genuinely think with support from folks  like yourself and thank you for your  belief in our mission I think we can  create a world where everyone truly has  access to a free world-class education